your imperial highness
hua mulan
it wasn't just the cast that made
disney's mulan look so beautiful the
ever popular disney live-action remakes
are loaded with some elaborate
prosthetics makeup and costumes and
their 2020 rendition of mulan is no
exception from the exceptional work of
the hair and makeup team as well as the
gifted costume designers here's what
went into the fashion and prosthetics of
mulan
cannot eat it will ruin your makeup the
fiercest winter storm could not destroy
this makeup one of the most unique
scenes in the film in terms of the
makeup and hair styling was the
betrothal scene denise coombe took
inspiration from artwork from the tang
dynasty which involved a white panel on
the top of a woman's forehead as well as
on the bridge of their nose come to this
historical style and also mixed in the
use of yellow as the color was very
popular during the period as it was
believed to bring a certain aura to the
forehead and was even thought to bring
good luck dark blue was used on the
eyebrows which was inspired by the
feathers of a peacock and lastly red
rouge was added because of all the thick
layers of makeup it was extremely hard
for liu yifei rosalind chao xana tang
and chung pepe to make the facial
expressions that were required for the
scene this is my sad face this is my
curious face
and i'm confused
gong lee's prosthetics had to be applied
on her hands right before she was
scheduled to be on set as once they were
applied she would have limited to no use
of her hands which made her very
uncomfortable after a while kum added
that lee was especially patient during
the lengthy process which along with the
prosthetics and airbrushed makeup also
included the application of a long wig a
crown and lashes
your witch am i
and who are you
nikki carrow told denise kum that she
wanted the villainous bori khan along
with his team to look tribal and nomadic
as well as ground dwelling if gold is
not enough i will give you blood
actor jason scott lee would sit for
hours on end in the makeup chair and
would make a variety of different faces
to allow kum to apply the scars in all
different sorts of areas where scars
weren't nearly as common [ __ ] compared
the process to applying facial tattoos
who will save you
five different types of the battle
attire were designed for the various
scenarios mulan had to endure one for
the underwater scenes another for riding
horseback and one for stunts they are
all made out of different fabrics in
different structures so that they can
work for all her stunts because of the
multiple thick layers it wasn't the
easiest outfit to perform in
particularly because liu yifei would
have to perform stunts underwater while
wearing the armor and it wasn't the most
comfortable experience for the young
actress it was for me really important
that she could move in her armor and in
all her costumes initially denise kum
was supposed to apply liu ife's makeup
on screen during the betrothal scene as
a stand-in for rosalind chow who plays
mulan's mother though the day the scene
was filmed kum was working with gong li
which led to georgia lockhart adams
serving as the stand-in adams was
actually deep into her pregnancy at the
time of filming so in order to keep her
belly from showing up on camera she had
to stretch her arms out the furthest she
could in order for her pregnant belly to
remain hidden
a girl a woman
a warrior liu efe had to be put in
multiple uncomfortable situations in
order for the makeup to not be worn away
by the stunts kum went on to say that
yfay had to execute a few in-camera
effects with tricks using a fishing line
wire with different hair pieces which
enabled her to move in a particular way
whether it was to tumble down come
unravelled riding horseback or in the
tea scene where she is balancing
precariously
one of the features that kum had to
focus on when distinguishing between
mulan's male look as well as her female
look yvee's eyebrows were thinned out
and less subtle when mulan is disguised
as a male but also more enhanced to look
more feminine liu yifei would have to
contour her face in different awkward
positions in order for the makeup
artists to make her eyebrows look more
like a man's
it's my duty to fight if i were your son
you wouldn't have to
mulan was actually filmed in several
different countries including the us
china and new zealand the film's
production would deal with all different
kinds of climates from snow wildfires
and extreme humidity wire work was even
done to make liu yifei's hair look more
natural which wasn't the most cozy
feeling kum stressed that hair is a
fiber that does not react the same in
all conditions so you'd have to mitigate
how to get the hair to look the same in
all these different countries it works
really well on screen since she plays
the title character it shouldn't come as
a surprise that liu jaffe had the most
designs on screen one of the biggest
challenges was applying the makeup for
when mulan is disguised as a man
need a hand little man
several tests were done so yfaye could
both look convincing as a male but also
appear as though she didn't have even a
speck of makeup on her nature nerves and
the action set pieces were another
obstacle in consideration when designing
the invisible makeup look kum claimed
that silhouette and shape were key to
differences between the male and female
form
he's a girl
for gong lee's villainous shinyan makeup
denise kum applied a white central panel
which was inspired by rice powder across
the top half of actress gongley's face
you have proved useful witch
don't twitch
warrior white was used as not only was
it seen as the color of mourning in
chinese culture but was also viewed as
one of the five elements standing for
moral purity during the qin and han
dynasty where a woman's morals were
considered more important than physical
beauty and the color of white was seen
as a symbol of power the mask-like
design had more theatrical origins
presenting something more mysterious and
more like a disguise as opposed to just
using eye shadow and makeup it was a
girl like you
when people turned on me shinyan's
costume was designed to look bird-like
especially since one of her most
prominent powers is transforming into a
hawk the costume was designed to include
silver scales as well as excessively
long sleeves a chest plate and an
elaborate headdress her crown was
actually inspired by the skull of a hawk
everything is just perfect for her bina
daigler said that she wanted to give the
character a costume that she could
actually fight in and with even using
her sleeves as a weapon on their own
i am the slave and you would do well to
remember it while most of the prosthetic
work was done with jason scott lee and
gong lee's bori khan shin young denise
kum also applied more subtle prosthetics
for the calmer characters as well subtle
makeup and prosthetics were used for
taima and rosalind chao for when their
characters appear older kum subtly used
both aging and de-aging makeup for both
actors you were always there yet i see
you for the first time when makeup and
hair stylist denise [ __ ] was first
brought on board mulan by director nikki
carrow the titular heroine hadn't even
been cast yet in fact she was brought on
two years before filming had actually
commenced with the start of production
being delayed because of how long it was
taking to find the perfect actress to
take on the role of mulan yifei is
indeed the only one that could ever have
played mulan during this time kum did
some lengthy research on the ballot of
mulan and its overall importance to
china by the time pre-production had
begun much of the research had already
been completed i was looking at a lot of
the old sculptures and the old scroll
paintings coomb wanted to make sure that
the makeup used in the film looked and
felt authentic to the film's setting kum
and her team had to look at what was
available when airbrushing white to
create a certain look we had to
experiment because you also have to find
what will work with the skin and how it
will layer with other ideas kum said she
wanted the makeup used to look more like
pigments or something out of nature like
a rice flour or as if it was grounded up
from paste i'm truly blessed to be in
the presence of such enchanting women
kum actually didn't use the 1998
animated film too much as a source the
only areas where kum drew directly from
the cartoon was the reflection scene
mainly because the hair comb is such an
integral part to that scene tranquilizer
forest but on fire within
the hair and makeup crew as well as the
costume designers had their work cut out
for them when working on mulan but it
paid off in the end from the highly
detailed costumes to the authentic use
of makeup the hard work in these areas
certainly left an impact on the film